Hello, visitors.
This is going to cover the advanced
chart types, sort of. They're
not the advanced charts that
you would create in Data 5400,
but it is using some familiar
chart types and creating them in a
more advanced way. So I will cover
how to create combined axis chart,
a dual axis chart, a bar and bar
chart, a cross tab, and also just
remind you how to create that
scatter plot and apply trend lines.
So let's go ahead and jump into our
AG advanced chart type start file
here and you should be on the
combined axis tab. So I want to just
create a simple bar chart here and
before I do I just want to remind you
that here we have the data pane
where you can drag and drop fields
in here to create your charts or you
can drag and drop them onto specific
columns and rows. So I'm interested
in sales and profit according
to market, and I'm going to go
ahead and grab sales and drop that
right here at the top. And you can
see it's been placed on the columns.
And then I'm going to
take the subcategory,
place that on rows. So now
I've got the subcategory
with accessories, appliances,
art, and so forth.
And now I'm going to add in market.
So I'm going to drag that and
put that right before sales
just so that it's right there
on the top. So now what I have
is the market of Africa with
the subcategories of the company
and then the sales. So I
can begin to see, okay, this
one is $96,674.12 for Africa
and the subcategory of storage.
Now, how to layer on another
measure, and that is profit. So I
might drag this and then drop
that in there. But when I do that,
you'll see that there are now two
columns, one for sales and one
for profit. And that's because
this is the default for Tableau.
This is what Tableau
wants to do whenever you
have measures. It will
create separate axes.
And so there is a workaround, and
that's this ability to do the combined
axes. So what we'll do is we'll
take profit off of that, and we'll
click it and drag and drop it and
place it in the axes down here. And
as soon as you do that, you'll see
that it turns into this equal sign.
it's a green equal sign. And when
I release the mouse, you'll see
that Tableau has added the profit
with the sales in a combined axis.
So now I no longer have it separate
in the columns, but now I have it
outlined here as a profit and sales
here as a combined axis. And in the
meantime, what Tableau has done is
it's actually done a workaround.
It's changed that to a measure value
and then a measure name, which allows
Tableau to only have still one measure,
but then it's now using profit on
this axis. And you can see I've got
a filter I've added here, and then
the measure values are right here.
So let me just go back so
you guys can see how that
happens. And so from there,
drag and drop, and you
can see now, those are much
more easier to recognize,
maybe high sales, low profit
areas, okay? Now, what if I wanted
to create a bar chart where I
can combine those two together?
I can do that by taking measure
names and dropping that onto color.
Now, for this particular demo,
this doesn't make a lot of sense
because now I've got orange as
sales and blue as profit and they're
stacked on top of each other. This
doesn't make any sense. It's better
to compare them side by side. But
I wanted to show you how you can
take that same measure name
and change the orientation
so that you can best
create the visualization
that will give you the most
insights for your user.
So this is a combined axes bar chart.
The next chart type is a
dual axis chart. So let's hop
back to our Tableau workbook
and create a dual axes.
So what I want to remind
you is that every time there
is a green field, there
needs to be an axis. So
that works if you want to
show the dual axes, right?
And the previous, when I showed
you I do the combined axes where
there's just one singular one,
that is necessary if you have
data that's very similar but if
what if you have data that has
very different numbers or different
scales then you'll want to do
a dual axis and that's when you
can have multiple access on the
Tableau data pane. So I'm
interested in doing sales over time.
So I'm going to go ahead and grab the
sales and I'm going to put that in my
row. Sorry about that. There we go.
And then I'm going to take order
date and bring that into my column.
And then I'm going to go ahead
and change that I should say
yours is probably going to show
that it has a line and then I'm
going to change that to be a
month okay so now that I have my
year here my month of order date
outlined and then also my sales but
again I wanted to also see how profits
track against sales so in order
to do that I just take profit right
here and I'm going to do another
feature similar to what we did
in the combined axis is to drag
that and you'll notice here I can
I can create that combined axis but
if I go to the far right it will
create another just single green column
and if I drop that then I've
created a dual axis so notice I have
on the right hand side I have one
axis and then one that's different
on the left hand. So now I can
begin to track the sales and the
profit to see if there's any insights
here. So here we saw a big huge
dip in profit in July, but sales
were rather high. So there's some
discounts that were placed. Now if
you want to, you can actually change
the axis here on the right. You
can synchronize the axes. If I do
that, you'll notice then this second
one becomes very flat. I don't see
a lot of that difference. So be
careful about whether that's going
to help or hinder your analysis.
Another thing that you should notice
is that because they're on different
axes, they have different abilities
to change their type. So here I
could go to my sales and I can
change that from a line to a bar
and now I can see, right, and I can
kind of see that difference as it's
tracking. I can also independently
change the color. So that is the
power of a dual axis and you just
drag out that measure to that far
right pane to apply that feature.
The next chart we'll take a
look at is a bar in bar chart.
So let's go back to our
worksheet here. And a great way to
compare measures is a bar chart.
And especially if you are thinking
about something like sales to
a sales target, because you can very
easily see whether you're reached
or exceeded the target and how
far away you are from doing so.
So in order to do that we need to
bring in some more information to this
particular data source and we've
already got this connection and you
can see we've got this clean data
that I've got and I want to add in
some sales targets. So I'm going to
use the ability to right-click our
data source. I'm going to say edit
data source and it will bring me back
here and i want to add a text file
here so i'll go ahead and select
that and then by doing that i can
navigate and you can navigate as well
to the location of where that csv file is
so i've got that sales target csv
file and i'll go ahead and open that
and then i'll go ahead and I will
drag that to this and drop it and
just like every time that you are
bringing in some new files you need
to make sure and share and show
that relationship and so down below
we'll go down to subcategory and
have the relationship with the
category okay all right so I'm gonna
go back to my sheet here and what I
want to do is to build my bar chart
showing sales per sub category
so what I'm going to do is put sales
on my column and then I'm going
to go ahead and take my subcategory
see subcategory and place that into
rows okay okay so now that we've
got all the subcategories what we
wanted to do is put that against
the sales target which is down below
here so if I go ahead and drag
the sales target next to the sales
you'll see that we have to access
because we've got two green measures
and if you remember what you learned
about when it came to combined
axis we're going to go
ahead and drag that off and
hopefully you remember
what to do before i do it
i hope that you remember
to take that sales target
and to drag that and place that right
here where the equal numbers is okay
so now we have the sales and sales
target stacked on top of each
other and just like we did for that
combined access I showed that you
could for clarity take that measure
name and then drop that on color
so now I have these two bars and
this is not a bar and bar chart
this is actually is stacked at
this point because I have both the
accessories and then I have the
subcategory and then I have the target.
So I have the sales target here
and they have the accessories here.
So this stacked bar, these two
stacked bars do show them separately
but in this case because we have
a target, oh and by the way I
changed this to orange so you could
better see that versus the purple.
You want to have both of them start
at zero. In order to do that you
need to go to the analysis tab at
the top and then select stacked
marks and turn that off. By default
it will be on but when I turn it off
you'll see that now these are
stacked with the starting point of
zero and I can see where my sales
target has sort of creeped above the
sales. Now, what happens for this
one, like an art where sales covers
has exceeded the sales target? I
still want to be able to see that.
And yes, you can do that
here within Tableau.
What you would do is you
would take measure names
and you will drag that
and place that onto size.
Now, by doing so, now you've got a line
here and then a thicker bar up on top.
Now you can change the size
relative to each other by just
doing this right here, but if
I want to change one versus the
other, the way I do that is I
go here to the right hand side,
click the down arrow,
say edit sizes, and now let me
just move this off to the side.
I can select sales and I can
create sort of that smaller area
and then apply, which will
create a larger blue bar or if I
want to go back down that's great
to move this down here and I
can apply and I could begin to
work with those different sizes.
So now you can easily see this
bar and bar chart where you
could identify certain ones
like phones where the sales
have exceeded the target and
fasteners where they have greatly
not exceeded the target. So
this is a bar in bar chart.
Now let's jump into the crosstab
and highlight table and back into
our Twibix file here and we'll
just create a simple crosstab
first of all. We'll take a look
at let's go for market. We'll put
that on columns and then we'll
take a look at subcategory in rows.
And I'm going to go ahead and
change this back to automatic.
And then we will go ahead and take
a look at sales. So when I'm using
a crosstab, just like you would in
Excel, it's really easy if you know
what you're looking for. So if I'm
looking for the sales in Canada for
labels, you can see I can quickly go
and find that it's 421 dollars and
74 cents so crosstabs are helpful
if you know what you're looking for
but what if you don't know what
you're looking for and you need some
additional insights this is where a
highlight table can come in handy so
let's go ahead and take sales and
drop that on color so what we've done
here is now added another way to look
at our sales based on this color.
The darker the color, the higher the
sales. But it's still very difficult
to read and not yet a highlight
table. So in order to do that in
Tableau, it's really simple. What
we'll do is we'll go to the marks card
and right now it's on text and we'll
change that from automatic to a
square and then by doing so I've
now created the color background to
articulate that that diverging palette
of color to show that so here it's
much more easier to see those darker
colors that have those higher sales
and then lower sales and of course
I can also edit that color and it's
automatic right now but I could change
that if there were some negative
colors typically that's when you
have the diverging palette but i
could create that middle mark and
change that maybe i'll make my middle
mark to sort of say um see it's in
advanced you could say i'll start it
at let's just say
say 200 okay and then that would
change that range you can also
do it as a step let me go and
change that. I'm going to go ahead
and change this back to blue
since they are all blue and then I
can do stepped and then maybe I
want to have just three steps here
and apply that and then I can
really begin to see some of those
outliers that I want to pinpoint
in my analysis. So this is how
you create a crosstab and then
convert it into a highlight table.
Our final chart is the scatter plot
which we're familiar with from our
basic chart types but I just want
to remind you about the features
of a scatter plot and how we can
ensure that we're using them to the
best of our ability here and so
what I want to do is just create a
scatter plot and remember we need to
have two measures one on columns one
on rows and in this case we'll go
ahead and drag profit up to columns
and then sales on to rows here
and I have my single mark but I'm
going to add some more details here
by putting category on color here
looks like I've already got my trend
line so let me remove that so that's
not there to distract you we've
got category on color and then we
will put quantity on size so we'll
add that then we'll add some more
detail by adding subcategory to the
detail and then product name on to
the detail okay so now we've got
plenty now you might be wondering
yours might look a little different
than mine and if that's the case
just be sure and select circle that
will fill that in and then once
that's filled in you can select color
and then you can add a border on
onto your scatterplot, especially
when you have lots and lots of them,
then it's helpful to have a little
bit of a border around that. And
so that's what I've done here. So
just as Dr. Hagman taught us, we can
add a trend line by right-clicking
here, and then we can select show
trend lines. And in this case, it's
going to show one for each of those
product categories for furniture,
office supplies and also the
technology and then I can also drag
right and drop to show the trend line
just for that highlighted area so
again on the fly tableau is able
to calculate that and provide those
trend lines all right so to remove
the trend lines just right click
and then click that again and that
will hide those trend lines so the
last reminder is adding that animation
element to that scatterplot to
show the progression if you have
that over time. So I'm gonna just
go ahead and remove this subcategory
to remove any confusion here, and we'll
just have these three single dots here.
And if you remember correctly
from that in-class demo
what we need to do to show
that over time, and that is to
grab the order date and to
put that on the pages shelf.
Once you do that, you have this
dialog box here on the right-hand side
where you can show that history, and
you can show those trails, right?
And then you can play that.
And we've got that going
at a certain rate here.
But you can play with those
different features. maybe I just want
to do the marks here and I will
maybe I'll keep them I'll do a
green here we'll do a little bit
of a fading and I can make them
fade higher or lower there so I
would definitely encourage you to
to play with it you can kind of
see here now I've got that green
I could make it into a gray with that
final zone so again scatter plots
require those two measures one on
columns, one on rows, and you can
add those trend lines and add that
animation to really help create
those insights and to show over time
what is happening with your data.